hi rich and adam
this is asha and savannah we are two
girls from
kelowna british columbia canada
and we have decided to run 500
kilometers barefoot
starting this run on june 21st 2021
so we're one month into training and
have just a few left
which is why as plant-based vegans we're
hoping to link arms with you
to receive the proper nutritional wisdom
to make those 500 kilometers
a success rich your journey to your
first
ultra gave us the confidence that we are
capable of this
feat we know we can do this
so call us anytime and as we like to say
keep rolling on awesome ciao
all right first of all a couple things i
feel like this is much more
about like hey rich will you call us
than it is
like a legitimate interest in in in me
answering this question no but this is
this
is calling them asha and savannah were
they both
talking back and forth it seemed like it
seemed like it yeah all right
i love these women this is awesome 500
kilometers barefoot
i like how they have only been training
a month and there's only like
two months left or less than two months
before they're gonna do this
so that's amazing i like that they're
plant-based vegans
and i'd be happy to link arms with them
maybe i should call them at some point
so wind in your sails this is very cool
i want to know more
about this adventure are they running on
pavement i suppose right or trails what
exactly is going on here do they have
roads
in calawanya british columbia
i think they do right that's a terrible
thing to say i think room
did they pave the roads up there that's
pretty far north
i'm just kidding um you guys are awesome
very cool i'm here to support you 100
and although i'm not sure you really
need any advice because i don't know
that that's what this is about
i think nutrition is very personal so
specifics i don't think are going to be
super helpful to you guys
like i said in the answer to the
previous question
test test test test all this stuff out
you guys have
you know plenty of time to work out your
nutrition regimen
in the lead up to this adventure so when
you start you should know exactly what
works for you and what doesn't
if you want to stay on the whole food
tip um what's worked for me
and what has worked for many other
people are things like sweet potatoes
which are easily digestible when you're
running at a low pace they kind of work
like nature's gels
dates are great almond butter is great
coconut water for
hydration i think you need to figure out
some estimate of how many calories
you're burning per hour
and then from that figure out how many
calories you need to be
you can reasonably take in on an hourly
basis
to make sure that you're replenishing
yourself as much as possible without
upsetting your stomach
and the upset stomach thing is the big
thing right like when you're testing
you have to almost overdo it to figure
out where that line is and which
foods your body is able to digest better
than others to figure out what's going
to work for you
and also understanding that no matter
what you do
when you're tackling an adventure like
this 500 kilometers barefoot
you are very quickly going to go into a
caloric deficit you're not going to be
able to eat
that much when you're running when
you're cycling it's a little bit easier
but
you're always going to be coming from
the rear in terms of meeting your body's
caloric needs
which means it's really important that
you figure out a schedule
so that you're taking in as much as you
can like i said without upsetting your
stomach
even when you're not hungry like
there'll be moments where you're like
i'm not eating you know and you need a
crew member who's going to say
we knew you were going to say that but
you have to eat right now because
you're not you're not eating for that
moment
you are eating for the following day so
even though if you feel great and you
don't want to put anything in your
stomach
you have to understand that's going to
impale your body's ability to repair
itself
and come back the next day and the next
day and the next day so super important
to stay on top of it
if you're open to some uh
performance nutrition products i can
shout out a couple of podcast sponsors
you can
for slow carbs they're great yes um it's
it's very easily digestible you can put
a ton of calories in a water bottle
and just sip it um and it will really
that's been very helpful especially for
something like would you highly suggest
you
would you suggest like regular like
every 30 minutes i'm gonna
i'm gonna have a sip every hour i'm
gonna have food
yeah it could be i mean everybody's
different like some people every 20
minutes
you know it's it's 50 calories or
something like that so you just create
this slow dri what you don't want to do
is like spike your blood sugar and then
have
uh and then have like a crash you know
that's that's what you're trying to
avoid so
the kind of slow carb um
like what would you call it the the the
the carbohydrates that are in something
like you can
are designed to not spike that blood
sugar but to kind of give you a slow
drip
you know of energy which is exactly what
you're looking for
for electrolytes you know coconut water
is great but you really want to make
sure that you're staying on top of that
proper ratio and balance so
element you know another podcast sponsor
they're great for that there's no sugar
artificial ingredients in that you know
i love it doing the the goggins thing
that'll work for you
so maybe check those out and make sure
that when
you're getting those rest periods the
recovery in between that you're doing
everything in your power
to um not just replenish those calories
but repair your body for the next day so
ice baths if that's possible if you
don't have a theragon i'm just shouting
out all the sponsors
but these are products that that work
and are helpful and to make sure that
you
you know are getting the sleep that you
need that's the most powerful recovery
enhancement
it looks like um kelowna is on a
fingerling
lake oh you look at the map just east of
vancouver
where it's like the british columbia
wine country area you know beautiful
there's one there's wine country up
there so i think that's where it looks
like
and so there it goes on the route right
but if they're near the lake maybe they
can get it
yeah there's no ice bath just like jump
in that lake for a while but i don't
know if they're doing this
are they are they do they have a crew
are they being supported
is there a van are they just going
straight through are they going to sleep
lots of questions how do you i feel like
it's they did that on purpose so then
now i have to call
them yes and how do you care for the
bare feet like when you're taking breaks
i don't know they gotta call tony riddle
i have no experience with that i really
don't know
but that's that's tony riddle's
department all right
anyway it was a wonderful question you
guys are amazing and we are
looking forward to hearing more about
your incredible run
sending you love and strength we are
all right i think we did it
so
[Music]
you